hey whats up guys mkbhd here back with
yet another YouTube update yeah you
heard that right I'll promise I'll stop
making these videos I promise if you
tube stops making updates but honestly
this is a great feature that YouTube is
added and it's a feature that allows
YouTube to go social you might have seen
a tweet by a couple of people including
me waffle john john for lakers things
like that but i'll go ahead and show you
firsthand that there is now very much
more nicely integrated feature for
sharing youtube videos you can see this
video suddenly reverse published 20
percent don't ask me why but this video
published yesterday which was new
comment sharing feature which is a big
part of going social on youtube and the
the general new look of the youtube
layout now what you can do if you
remember when you hit that share button
before you could have a couple of share
options but if you've ever been to a
site like YouTube got our I'm sorry
mashable com or engadget or gizmodo you
might see a little tweet button inside a
little buzz button in the slide to share
it on google buzz now when you go to a
YouTube video you'll have those same set
of options which is fairly impressive so
up top you have the number of times it's
been buzzed and you can click there to
buzz it you can have the there's a
number of times this video's have been
tweeted so thanks to those of you who
shared it on Twitter and you can also
share it on Facebook you can also
shortened URL by clicking here and i'll
have the y 0 to y 0 UT ube link or
unshorn it and have an HD URL which is
an HD equals 1 at the end so that's a
really cool feature that you can just
grab that link right there and share it
or just that tweet button and post it to
Twitter you also have of course email or
curd blog or live spaces myspace what's
that whatever myspace delicious Reddit
and stumble upon all in this one area
you also have your Facebook Twitter and
Google Reader accounts connected for
when you upload videos but i'll probably
do that later just because it adds a
couple of new integration features but
that's really the general new look of
youtube sharing of videos so now you can
not only share videos with you know
copying and pasting a link from the top
but you can just use the share button
feature right here so if you want to
share this video you can most likely do
so see how many times it's been shared
below so you can also share YouTube
comments and share playlists and things
like that etc so that's just the the
gist of it and the new way to share
YouTube video
so until next time this is Ben mkbhd
with another YouTube update video
signing out peace